we met the most amazing princess  but they ran away and all they left  behind was this  everyone there's something i need to  tell you  the princess who came to your ball  tonight  was me  i'm gonzarella  but gonzo why didn't vu tell us  because you all expected me to look a  certain way  see this is why it's so important have a  father in the home it's clear that gonzo  doesn't have a father in the home to say  hey take that thing off you look stupid  get that thing off of you i would take  that off  that looks crazy you know if you've  raised your your kids correctly and they  and they were to watch them up at babies  and they saw that  they would start laughing like if my  boys watch my babies which they won't  but if they did and they saw they would  just laugh hysterically because they  would say that's so silly and ridiculous  which it is but now it's the the  the goal is quite the opposite of that  which is among other things extremely  creepy